on les surnomme les enchanter
à mille kilomètres au large de
l'équateur au coeur de l'océan pacifique
les îles des galapagos offre un paradis
écologique unique au monde quasi
inaccessible sauf pour quelques chanceux
comme adriana est mauvais
moi la vraie musique
mais
pour
ce couple d'influenceurs équatorien
explosive dessin cristobal à la
recherche des plus beaux spots
et bien j'ai voyagé dans sexy et dans
point sinon et je n'ai jamais
c'est un rêve d'être ici c'est le rêve
de tous les albums
adriana tient d'un bloc de voyages subie
par plus de dix mille abonnés ces photos
des galapagos sont les plus commentés
les galapagos sont un endroit
extrêmement
il y a peu de moi et
là il y en à venir ici et là-bas newell
il sans parler du monde
moins de 300 mille touristes par an et
parmi eux deux célèbres vacanciers comme
arnold schwazenegger
jennifer lopez tom cruise mais aussi
angelina jolie et brad pitt
pour mettre en lumière cette veste il
assure vip adriana a repéré cette crique
caché au pied d'une colline elle fera
partie l'an prochain du circuit mondial
de surf sur ses vagues glisseront les
plus grands champions de la planète au
milieu des loups de mer
soul surfer qui est un privilège et non
la
carte est l'un des meilleurs spots du
monde a peur mais plus d'être à la
connexion avec les animaux rend
l'expérience inoubliable est super
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco les soixante et une îles des
galapagos ont d'un sanctuaire
certaines des espèces n'existe que sur
cette terre coupées lieux fermés pendant
six mois pour cause de pandémie elle
reprend doucement leurs portes et offre
un spectacle unique où la nature a plus
que jamais repris ses droits dans
quelques instants
ne vous en moquez
douce terre de feu et l'enchantement
aux galapagos volant sur l'océan
pacifique celso est ici chez lui ce
guide touristique est l'un des rares à
connaître l'archipel comme sa poche
regardez une raie manta
coupé du monde saisit longtemps été
réservé aux aventuriers intrépides
mais en 2010 une exposition
exceptionnelle a fait venir des dizaines
de stars de hollywood tout engagé dans
l'écologie comme leonardo dicaprio glenn
close ou encore le milliardaire bill
gates
celso amené cette expédition
baptisé et wish
ça c'est le résultat de la protection
des océans
avec les charlots la docteure s'il
d'ailleurs la reine yu galapagos des
gens très influents dans des artistes de
cinéma leonardo dicaprio par exemple
qu'on a décidé de soulever des fonds
pour pouvoir envoyer ses stars dans
différents pays et persuader les
gouvernements de créer plus de réserves
marines comme celle que nous avons aussi
un gars la table
pendant plusieurs jours le guide a fait
découvrir à ses célébrités la beauté
mais aussi la fragilité de l'archipel
là on est en train de visites o'neal
était descendu en goût moi je prenais
des photos il y avait une odeur de
caprion regarder il est là tout seul
cette photo je les prises avec la prise
jack et tout à coup on a vu des hommes
juste à côté de nous elle était en train
de chasser une tortue elles l'ont
assommée et laurent guti
nous on était scotché parce qu'on était
vraiment très proches d or et elle
soufflait fort et les choses étaient
très éléments et ne croyez pas
à la suite de cette expédition des
dizaines de nouvelles réserves mari
jour
[Musique]
regarde l'émission
incroyables
aux galapagos la réserve s'étend sur
plus de 130 mille kilomètres carrés soit
la taille de l'angleterre
extrêmement protégé ppe-de ils sont
accessibles aux visiteurs celle de
bartolomé est l'une des rares à tolérer
la présence humaine mais il faut monter
plus de 350 marche pour atteindre le
sommet
c'est la carte postale des galapagos
tout le monde connaît la fameuse pierre
pointue elle est sur toutes les vidéos
et les photos des galapagos c'est ici
qu'a été tourné master et commandeur le
premier unifiée mains libres d'autoriser
aux galapagos
interprété par russell crowe ce film
retrace l'histoire d'un marin anglais au
19e siècle il sera nommé 10 fois aux
oscars
il affirmé depuis le sommet ici aussi
sur la plage ça vous voyez là bas c'est
une blague la sciatique cela qu'ils ont
créé ça
mais même pour hollywood l'accès à cette
plage a été au départ refusé celle ci a
dû intervenir pour aider l'équipe du
film à obtenir une autorisation
exceptionnelle
on est complètement seul ici il n'y a
rien pour gâcher le paysage et on
profite pleinement notre coexistence
avec les animaux et c'est ça que le
gouvernement d'équateur votre protégé et
on espère que le reste du monde s'en
inspire parce qu'il existe des
écosystèmes merveilleux un peu partout
il faut les protéger
pour limiter la présence humaine seuls
cinq ils sont habités mais depuis une
vingtaine d'années des hôtels de grand
luxe ont vu le jour
comme ici dans l'une des rares forêts
tropicales de l'archipel se niche le
thème de prédilection des célébrités
jégo et le manager de cette propriétaire
du commun
[Applaudissements]
là c'est une villa de 85 m² duisans
quatre chambres
la décoration est minimaliste le vrai
luxe des galapagos c'est l'environnement
comme vous le voyez nos fenêtres
panoramiques connect la chambre avec la
nature environnante et on est au chaud
et au sec ici à l'intérieur
pour limiter le nombre de visiteurs sur
une île il est interdit d'y construire
de nouveaux hôtels
c'est cette exclusivité qui a attiré les
vacanciers les plus célèbres de la
planète
[Musique]
notre premier hôte a été le président
équatorien de l'époque
ensuite nous avons beaucoup de clients
importants comme michael schumacher ou
harrison ford
nous avons également reçu angelina jolie
et brad pitt lorsqu'ils sont descendus
en ville ils ont une expérience un peu
chaotique mais chez nous ils ont pu
profiter tranquillement de leurs
vacances
mais le visiteur qui a le plus marqué
l'hôtel c'est le prince charles la suite
présidentielle
aujourd'hui en travaux a même été
renommé en son honneur mais ce n'est pas
le seul héritage calais c 'est tout
royal
le tpr est
ça c'est le service à thé en argent
qu'on a fait venir spécialement
d'angleterre il ya cinq ans
il y avait un protocole très rigide qui
avaient respecté mais le couple royal
lui était très simple très humain est
réellement selon notre personnel on
aurait dit des clients comme les autres
[Musique]
tombé en amour pour l'archipel le prince
charles a décidé de s'engager dans sa
préservation est seul de ses habitants
les plus célèbres qui ont d'ailleurs
donné leur nombre aux galapagos les
tortues géantes sur l'île de santa cruz
elles se promènent en liberté à leur
rythme vicaut a ouvert les six une
réserve où les touristes du monde entier
viennent d'observer les tortueux dans
leur milieu naturel
quand j'étais petit et jouer avec les
tortures monter dessus c'était il ya
quarante deux ans pas ça pour la
situation est très différente
aujourd'hui elle constate combien ces
tortues sont importantes comme tous les
animaux des gardes alternées il convient
nous devons les protéger nous avons la
chance d'avoir des animaux n'y a pas si
affreux y faire attention
depuis la pandémie et la chute du
tourisme vicaut a recensé deux fois plus
de tortue que d'ordinaire
regardez moi celle ci allait
complètement relaxe n'est pas tes tirs
et personne ne la dérange pas qu'il
[Musique]
doive des tortues concrètement ce qu'il
se passe certes pas la nature il a fallu
que la nature elle-même le tire les
oreilles avec l'accord de prêt s'il
trouvait agir plus vite et respecter les
a mollo et leurs écosystèmes
[Musique]
la protection de ces tortues est
aujourd'hui la priorité de l'île car il
ne reste plus que 6 % de la population
originelle pour leur venir en aide ces
scientifiques ont ouvert un centre de
reproduction
[Musique]
218 g leur travail a fait le tour du
monde et attirer de nombreuses
célébrités
j'ai eu la chance d'être là quand le
prince charles est venu il apparaît une
tortue mais aussi leonardo dicaprio et
l'acteur de pirates des caraïbes johnny
depp et bien d'autres
beaucoup de stars galapagos pour
promouvoir l'importance de la
préservation des espèces
[Musique]
elles connaissent plus que quiconque la
fragilité des cas là bas nous africains
et sa soeur x aura ont été élevés par
leurs parents sur l'île de san cristobal
sans eau courante ni électricité
elles font partie des rares privilégiés
au monde avoir grandi sur ces îles
sauvages
c'est génial l'eau est très claire
on voit déjà les têtes de tout ce qui
sort de l'eau
leurs endroits préférés
c'est cette plage où les loups de mer
donne naissance à l'emploi
c'est que tu n'as pas besoin
nous ne bouge pas et tu te permettre de
prendre
la pose
les deux soeurs ont appris à nager avant
de savoir marcher à seulement 8 ans pour
les habituer à la vie sauvage des
galapagos leur père les jeter à l'eau au
milieu des requins
[Musique]
depuis les sirènes sont devenus
professeurs de projets et accompagne les
touristes en quête de grand bleu
mais aussi d'expérience brancher
le soir elles retrouvent leurs amis dans
le dernier né des écolodges de lille la
jeune influence ou adriana est aussi
présente pour attirer la jeunesse dorée
équatorienne
bonsoir bonsoir renato enchanté comment
vas-tu
renato et le jeune manager de l'hôtel
fermé pendant plusieurs mois à cause de
la pandémie il a fait appel à adriana
pour relancer son activité
la nature c'est le nouveau luxe avant le
luxe c'était d'être confortable chez soi
maintenant c'est connaître des lieux
sauvages ils se reconnecter avec la
nature et les galapagos sur le meilleur
endroit au monde pour cela
[Musique]
l'hôtel dispose d'une usine de
dessalement de l'eau y est cette fille
sinon justement le résultat car c'est la
première et unique single
[Musique]
les canards dans la piscine en sont le
meilleur exemple les animaux sont rois
hùng et pas nous
[Musique]
et pour accueillir une nouvelle
clientèle soucieuse de respecter
environnement et sécurité l'hôtel a misé
sur de nouvelles technologies a encore
jamais vue aux galapagos
un regarde la cabine d'ozone je vais
faire une story voici la caverne aux
zones de l'hôtel où ils devaient entrer
dedans est resté neuf secondes pour
désinfecter tous les virus et bactéries
que vous apportez de la ville 1 c'est
l'une des mesures blessé a été imposé
par l'hôtel
mais pas question de quitter l'hôtel
sans tester son fameux jacuzzi sous les
étoiles
vous n'imaginez pas ce niveau là
juste pour seuls compagnons sont les
excuses qu'il donne alors une magie
conseil d'état je me sens présidera
chanceuse de trévise
preuve que les galapagos pourrait
devenir une nouvelle destination est
jeune et tendance
l'archipel a désormais son tout premier
groupe de musique top
frédéric au chanteur est le fils d'un
célèbre magicien equateur
jamais reconnaissants d'avoir grandir
dans un endroit aussi exceptionnel de
médias libanais ont trouvé de nature et
de liberté loin des maux de la société
tous les grands partis de la grèce
la jeunesse n'est pas la peine
[Musique]
l entente
c'est aussi les autres
[Musique]